y
[Música]
los talibanes aguardan a las puertas de
kabul y el gobierno se prepara para una
transición pacífica del poder según
informó el ministerio del interior los
insurgentes llegaron esta mañana
mientras miles de militares
estadounidenses aseguran la evacuación
del personal de la embajada
el rápido avance del grupo talibán en
afganistán genera miedo y nerviosismo
entre mujeres y niñas por las estrictas
reglas islámicas que se aplicaron cuando
los insurgentes gobernaron el país entre
1996 y 2001 ahora estarían a punto de
perder los logros en cuanto a sus
derechos y libertades que tanto les ha
costado conseguir
entre los escombros los haitianos
continúan la búsqueda de desaparecidos
tras el terremoto de magnitud 7,2 que
sacudió la isla y deja al menos 300 4
muertos los hospitales al suroeste del
país se encuentran colapsados y las
autoridades intentan trasladar a los
heridos hacia otras zonas en medio de la
afectación de carreteras
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz comenzamos en afganistán la
temida noticia de la entrada de los
talibanes a kabul la capital le llegó y
está asediada por todos los frentes sin
embargo dijeron que no tomarían el
control por la fuerza el ministerio de
interior informó que habría una
transferencia pacífica del poder a un
gobierno de transición conformado por
los insurgentes que horas antes ya se
habían tomado las ciudades de
mazar-i-sharif y jalal-abad ya son en
total 28 ciudades bajo su dominio de las
34 provincias que tiene el país
mientras tanto eeuu se evacua su
embajada y elevó a 5000 los militares
para garantizar la seguridad de sus
connacionales manuel acá no nos amplia
los talibanes se toman cada ciudad más
grande de afganistán y con más de 4
millones y medio de habitantes el
ministro interior afgano comunicó que se
hará una transferencia pacífica del
poder
man panamá y las fuerzas militares están
en kabul para proteger la seguridad las
fuerzas internacionales también están
para apoyarlos ayer el presidente
decidió enviar una delegación a doha
para buscar un acuerdo vamos a mantener
la seguridad hasta que haya un acuerdo
en la mañana del sábado el grupo
insurgente se había tomado
mazar-i-sharif y jalal-abad en la mañana
del domingo horas más tarde se hicieron
con vania mm aidan bakr los talibanes
controlan 28 de las 34 capitales
provinciales además se hicieron con
bagram la principal base aérea
estadounidense según dijo el portavoz de
los talibanes todos los presos fueron
liberados los talibanes controlan 26 de
las 34 capitales de provincia miles de
afganos huyendo de la guerra se
refugiaron en la capital que ahora será
custodiada por las fuerzas talibanes
agarramos la situación continúa así en
afganistán entonces queremos que eeuu
vuelva y nos dé armas
para de la comarca
este sábado el presidente joe biden
anunció que cinco mil soldados serían
enviados a kabul dos mil más de los
planeados anteriormente sin embargo las
banderas talibanes ya ondean en las
principales ciudades afganas avanzada
que comenzó con una velocidad sin
precedentes desde que las tropas
estadounidenses dejaron el país que
habían ocupado durante más de dos
décadas
el rápido avance del grupo talibán en
afganistán ha dejado a las mujeres y
niñas en las posiciones más vulnerables
ahora están a punto de perder los logros
en cuanto a sus derechos y libertades
que tanto les ha costado conseguir este
domingo el portavoz del talibán dijo que
se respetaran sus derechos y que podrán
salir solas de sus hogares
para muchas mujeres afganas estas
imágenes son una pesadilla hecha
realidad el rápido avance del grupo
talibán hasta que sus vidas corran
peligro
ya estamos escuchando y viendo informes
de niñas y adolescentes que son
arrebatadas de sus familias y entregadas
a los insurgentes para ser obligadas a
casarse ya está ocurriendo las escuelas
están cerrando
stern y si los insurgentes toman kabul
las consecuencias para las mujeres serán
catastróficas cuando los islamistas
gobernaban el país entre 1996 y 2001
impusieron una versión estricta de la
ley islámica las mujeres tenían
prohibido salir sin un hombre a su lado
trabajar o recibir educación quienes
eran acusadas de delitos como el
adulterio eran azotada si a pedradas
hasta la muerte en las zonas controladas
por el grupo talibán en la actualidad
estas normas ya están entrando en vigor
búscalo aragón en jota colocó no muevas
juanes zonas está está no en todas las
mujeres afganas tienen problemas
psicológicos no sólo aquí las mujeres no
salen mucho y no se ven mucho
muchas están optando por huir casi
250.000 afganos han huido de sus hogares
desde finales de mayo el 80 por ciento
de ellos son mujeres y niños y chipper
situación resulta especialmente
horripilante y desgarrador ver cómo se
arrebatan a las niñas y mujeres más
canas los derechos que tanto les ha
costado conseguir rondan en el primer
semestre de 2001 las mujeres y los niños
representaron casi la mitad de las
víctimas civiles de la guerra afgana
para entender lo que está pasando allí
nos acompaña el doctor moisès garduño
profesor de la facultad de ciencias
políticas y sociales de la unam y
especialista de temas de medio oriente
gracias por estar con nosotros y
cuéntenos qué significa la llegada de
los talibanes a kabul y su eventual
retorno al poder después de 20 años
bueno yo creo que significa el fracaso
de la política exterior norteamericana
en afganistán
ha representado incluso el fracaso en
aquellos momentos de la guerra fría de
la unión soviética hoy lo es de eeuu y
sobre todo pues por el desgarrador
el enfoque que hay por ejemplo del
desempleo de un 12 por ciento ciudades
totalmente divididas y ahora el regreso
de una fuerza de un poder fáctico que ha
estado prácticamente dominando pues
algunas provincias desde hace años y
ahora pues también aprovechando el vacío
institucional
yo creo que básicamente lo que estamos
viendo ahora es el fracaso de una
estrategia que gastó aproximadamente
700 mil millones de dólares la
administración estadounidense desde el
año 2001 hasta lo que se tenía reportado
en el 2019 cosa que pues sí son muy
felices a los principales
corporativos armamentistas de eeuu y
algunos de europa pero muy poco a los
ciudadanos y ciudadanas afganas
a este fracaso al que usted se refiere
puede deberse el hecho de que el
gobierno afgano esté facilitando una
transición del poder luego de que había
prometido frenar los avances de los
talibanes
yo creo que el gobierno afgano siempre
tuvo debilidades precisamente porque los
talibanes nunca dejaron de controlar
rutas estratégicas para el trasiego de
opio por ejemplo en los talibanes nunca
dejaron de tener armas necesarias para
poder defender esos territorios y pues
lamentablemente para bien o para mal el
gobierno afgano o encareció de
estrategias eficaces va a irse volando
pues ese poder y yo que los talibanes
nunca dejaron creo que el vacío
institucional que tenemos ahora también
tiene que ver con el interés que tiene
organista para otras potencias que ahora
también están preocupadas el china india
irán por ejemplo son países que van a
estar ahora muy alertas para evitar que
afganistán caiga en un caos que me
parece que lo mejor para los países que
rodean las fronteras de afganistán ahora
es que afganistán no caiga en una guerra
civil sino que como bien se ha comentado
por parte del gobierno afgano pues la
transición puede hacerlo más pacífico
posible debido a que un escenario de
guerra civil será catastrófico pues no
solamente para los países -insisto
aledaños sino también para la propia
población acan doctor garduño la
comunidad internacional ya avanza en la
evacuación de sus connacionales en
afganistán están dejando solo al país
no no están dejando solo lo que pasa es
que la hagan evacuación se tenía
planificada para unos seis meses pero no
se contaba con el avance tan rápido que
están teniendo los talibanes de hecho
han venido a sacudir esos planes de
evacuación y ahora no se han tomado las
medidas necesarias para acelerar eso más
que por el envío de cinco mil tropas más
por parte de eeuu y alguna algunos
esfuerzos de porte el negociador en doha
esto en qatar pero me parece que no es
que hayan dejado solos sino que la
estrategia ha sido fallida de igual
forma lo fue en irak por ejemplo también
que fue de un país que se invadió dos
años después de haber entrado a
afganistán y también ha sido fallida en
otros casos de ayuda como lo estamos
viendo por ejemplo ahora mismo en líbano
también donde ahora no hay combustible
para la población de ese país no
entonces ha sido algo sistemático que
tenemos que aprender también a dar
fórmulas más allá del armamentismo sobre
todo el desarrollo
de bienestar institucional
ahora hay reportes de ciudadanos
intentando ir desesperados del país
hacia sus vecinos inmediatos como
pakistán por ejemplo hasta dónde va a
llegar esta crisis humanitaria
esto es algo que nos puede dar pistas de
la situación humanitaria en caso de que
no haya esta transición pacífica de la
cual hablamos países como irán también
están recibiendo muchísima población de
corte en hazara de corte incluso también
pasto que pues puede ser población se
podría pensar cercana a los talibanes
pero que como estamos viendo pues están
saliendo del país yo creo que lo que
buscan estas personas que están saliendo
mucho ojo son las personas que tienen
los recursos necesarios para migrar son
aquellos que pueden entablar un viaje
hacia las fronteras y poder salir del
país la gran mayoría del país tenemos
que recordar que el índice de desempleo
por ejemplo está cerca del 14 por ciento
no pueden emigrar no puede salir del
país y eso es lo preocupante el talibán
también tiene un gran riesgo que es
desarrollar a una población que
históricamente ha sido empobrecida y ha
sido lanzada pues a una especie de
conflicto de atenciones latentes vamos a
ver si los talibanes van a poder hacer
esto y si lo van a contar con el apoyo
de algún país como por ejemplo china que
está muy interesado en que esto insisto
no caiga de la que hemos tenido en las
últimas dos décadas
muchas garduño especialista en temas de
medio oriente muchas gracias por
acompañarnos en france 24 y cambiamos de
tema porque al menos 304 personas han
muerto y hay centenares de heridos y
desaparecidos tras el terremoto de
magnitud 7,2 en el sur de haití ha
ocurrido ayer en la mañana a unos 12
kilómetros de la localidad de saint
louis du sud hay cuantiosos daños
materiales agravando la difícil
situación del empobrecido país caribeño
y es probable que las cifras de los
afectados vayan en aumento el primer
ministro ariel henrry declaró la
emergencia y prometió coordinar la
asistencia para que no se repitan los
errores del terremoto de 2010 del cual
el país aún no se ha recuperado esta
catástrofe golpea en plena crisis
institucional por el asesinato del
presidente lleven el móvil y sanitaria
por el impacto del cobi 19 el terremoto
forma parte de los 10 sismos más letales
de los últimos 25 años en latinoamérica
para hablar de esta situación nos
comunicamos con edison damas analista
internacional y ex presidente del cob
big convit club al haitiano en córdoba
argentina muy buenos días haití vive una
crisis social política y sanitaria y
económica que se agudizó con el
asesinato del presidente yo venía el
morís y con la pobreza estructural que
se espera para el país ahora que es
golpeado por este terremoto
buenos días y bueno lo que se espera
para el país es imprevisible porque la
crisis sea ahome se ha llegado tan grave
que uno no puede no pueden predecir qué
se puede que va a pasar primero estamos
en una crisis es una crisis
institucional
constitucional también porque con la
muerte de ellos en el móvil
no había cargos constitucionales que
podría romper reemplazarlo y las
instituciones tampoco funcionaban y
aquí está afectado por un terremoto y en
el cono sur
que digamos toda la zona sur del país
que está pasando de este modo en este
momento haciendo esta crisis se va
empeorando la situación en esta zona
porque estás esta zona ya era una zona
muy afectada por toda la crisis en el
país el hambre se va a aumentar la
condición de desempleo en las cifras de
desempleo se va a aumentar y en todo
todo va a ir aumentando para mal para el
mal del país y para el mal y sus gentes
de nuestro compatriotas instala ya
está en su fiel edición cómo cubrir las
numerosas deficiencias del estado ahora
con esta tragedia
el estado tenemos un estado ausente
tenemos un estado que también por ser un
estado de un país calificado como
neocolonia
de los países imperialistas el estado no
trabajaba digamos en los mejores tiempos
y hoy en día para cubrirlo esperando
partes del listado no nos va a pasar
nada lo que se está viendo en las
imágenes es lo que por lo menos una
forma de cubrir los
decadencia o la ineficiencia del estado
gente es el pueblo poniendo a usted de
la mano en las piedras centrándose en
los escombros para sacar a sus seres
queridos queridos
familiares que están en distintos otros
países viendo cómo ayudar y
para salir de esto para que sea hacer un
aporte más más útil al país es
necesitamos una solidaridad una
solidaridad plena con respecto a la
autoridad y determinación de este pueblo
con respecto a lo que quiere este pueblo
no quieren ganar
hacer lo mismo que pasa en los lugares
porque
hace 11 años ya que pasó el terremoto
y bueno las estructuras siguen lo mismo
siguen iguales seguían iguales y no
queremos que volvemos volver a esto que
la comunidad internacional por ejemplo
se toma la en el encargo todo todo lo
que es la la gestión y el manejo de la
crisis y al final si no se ve nada y
precisamente hablando de esto ya varios
países anunciaron su intención de
socorrer a haití pero qué garantías hay
de que no se repita lo ocurrido en 2010
cuando las ayudas no se vieron
reflejadas en la reconstrucción de la
isla luego del terremoto
no hay ninguna gran realmente no hay
porque ya lo hemos vivido lo hemos
vivido con con el terremoto esta zona
que está afectada en lo que se fue
afectado por uno por el huracán matthew
también la comunidad internacional había
dicho que va a borrar pero no sirve
excede porque lo que necesitamos lo que
necesita el pueblo es una una ruta que
permite el desarrollo que permite a a
atacar la isla infraestructura del país
y no hay ninguna garantía el estado no
funciona el estado que primero debería
garantizar que esta ayuda sea eficiente
que no vuelve a pasar lo que está
pasando lo que ha pasado en las leyes
este estado no está personal no está no
no está trabajando por ejemplo hay un
corte entre el sur y el resto del país
sólo por una zona que se llama matizan
donde bandas armadas se ocupan todo este
lugar y nos dejan pasar y el estado de
recién ayer a las 7 a las 5 6 de la
tarde y estaban tratando de llegar claro
está al sur y no solamente me cae que es
una de la ciudad de más afectada pero
también al sur western grandes el seremi
donde también son zonas muy alejadas
ya terrestre no se puede ir por ahí
las estructuras portuarias también
fueron afectadas y entonces si cuando
edison tenemos este tipo de instaló si
muchas gracias por lamentablemente se
nos acabó el tiempo pero muchas gracias
por su colaboración con france24 y
cambiamos de tema porque al menos 28
muertos y 79 heridos dejó una explosión
de un tanque de combustible al norte de
líbano el accidente se produjo cuando el
ejército entregaba a residentes locales
la gasolina que había decomisado del
mercado ilegal el siniestro se da de
medio de la escasez de combustible
agravado por la crisis económica social
y política que azota al país los
detalles desde beirut con nuestra
corresponsables del momento
en plena crisis del combustible el
accidente mortal de esta madrugada en la
ciudad fronteriza da la cara por la
explosión de un camión cisterna con
gasolina es otro ejemplo más de cómo el
líbano está atrapado entre la corrupción
y la negligencia aunque todavía se
desconocen las causas del incidente
medios locales dijeron que el ejército
había detenido al camión en cuestión que
transportaba gasolina subsidiada para
ser vendida en el mercado negro en síria
ahora que en el líbano hay mucha escasez
de combustible los hospitales han
advertido que en los próximos días
podrían dejar de funcionar si no se
resuelve el problema de los subsidios
para la importación de combustible la
decisión del banco central de quitar las
subvenciones a la gasolina ocurre en un
momento en el que los libaneses
prácticamente dependen de los
generadores de diésel para tener
electricidad porque hay 20 horas de
apagones diarios
esto también ocurre en medio de la peor
crisis económica y si se mantienen o se
levantan los subsidios significaría que
dos galones de gasolina equivaldría al
sueldo medio de un libanés
y vamos a hong kong porque el grupo
prodemocracia que organizó las mayores
protestas contra el gobierno en 2019
anunció su disolución el frente de
derechos humanos civiles creado en 2002
y compuesto por una serie de
organizaciones dijo en un comunicado que
ya no podía operar citando la represión
a la que se han visto sometidos por
parte de las autoridades su decisión se
da mientras se enfrenta a una
investigación policial por presunta
violación a la ley de seguridad nacional
china que entró en vigor el año pasado
y antes de despedirnos los invitamos a
visitar nuestra página web www france24
puntocom en portada una actualización
sobre la llegada de los talibanes a
kabul la capital de afganistán
hasta aquí esta informativa en france 24
pero los invitamos a que continúen con
toda nuestra programación quédense con
nosotros
[Música]